oh [ __ ]
monday
whatever the [ __ ] is it
monday
march 20th who the [ __ ] do you think
you're dealing with
on it
is the main sponsor of the church of
what's happening now go to honor.com
right now and press encode word church
and get 10 off
number two listen elevate your underwear
game to the next level you perfected
your wardrobe now get the party started
there's nothing better out there than me
undies meundiesnot.com
right now i'll get you 20 off your first
pair go ahead revamp your underwear draw
number two let me tell you something
cso is getting up there you understand
me with specials from nick apollo gina
yeah
and a new special from fajim aboard
right now you get
ceso for 3.99 a month but wait right
there if you go to cso.com right now
sign up for two free weeks with the
promo code joey that's how i'm doing it
tonight forget the 3.99 i'm going to
give you two weeks
code word jelly there you go who do you
think you're dealing with joy bananas
kick that mule lee
oh [ __ ]
just when you thought it was
safe take it to the next level lee come
on blow their [ __ ] earphones out we
here we go
it's your lucky day [ __ ]
it's the church of what's happening now
[ __ ] coming at you take these little
sticks right here here we go here we go
oh [ __ ] it's mission
impossible willie barcelana
lee syed
uncle joey coming at you
here we go oh
stop it
here we go
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here
lee syed my main man willie barcelona
what's happening what's up bro hi
good hang out with you
you are
all right what's up with you there lisa
i had an amazing i had something happen
that never happened in my life before i
left vegas with more money than i went
there oh [ __ ] look at you amazingly
practicing like you work like you said
it actually worked i've been playing
like every week for like two two months
or something like that a month and a
half
and i did work on this week
uh probably thursday i think this no no
no not to vegas just to uh somewhere
around here i would love to go again
this week but uh
no it was um i love vegas i don't i i
understand for comedians if you're stuck
there for like a week that must oh it
sucks dick
long week [ __ ] blows man by wednesday
you want to shoot yourself you're
hearing ding ding ding ding ding
you've already [ __ ] drank
it was i don't know it just didn't work
unless you don't really have a lot of
money to gamble like it's not like
that's why people go to spend money i
think i liked i like i i liked the short
week i did one of those long weeks one
time at the luxor right when it was
catch a rising star assignment it was
just he's got three shows a night yeah
three shows were fun yeah that that's
crazy yeah shows for [ __ ] 50 or
something like that
it was [ __ ] ridiculous then i liked
reno reno was a little bit uh
a little bit more
how do you say that the gymnastic wall
what i'm saying what you see in reno is
what you get yeah but uh that club i
liked because it was an easy five shows
i featured you know then i went and on
fridays they paid you so the guy was
cool you have to wait till sunday and
[ __ ] so i liked it because of that but
i don't know i don't i never did well a
whole week at a [ __ ] casino man i was
in baltimore
last weekend if you came to one of the
shows thank you very much
the shows were great the city was great
you know the day i left somebody threw a
[ __ ] fire bomb into a building and
killed two teenagers they don't [ __ ]
around in baltimore dog
first i got there on a
like one thing i'll never do again is
take a [ __ ] red eye
that is it that is it
that was the last time the painful man i
missed my last red eye
and uh and you miss your red eye you
just go home
yeah no there's no next flight bro you
know
there's a one this is what people don't
understand over
and again i hate to be this [ __ ] guy
30 years ago when you got on an 11
o'clock flight if there was 80 people on
the flight 40 of them were drinking
it was more the lights were on in the
back if you wanted to drink you walk to
the back you can hang out you can switch
your seats
today you can't do that these planes are
[ __ ] packed
to the brim
they turn the lights out i can't sleep
on a plane you know i always thought
whenever i do edibles and get on a plane
i go [ __ ] crazy at night in the
daytime it's fine but at nighttime
willie i go crazy i start sweating and
my legs won't stop that [ __ ] at night
that you get i never get that people say
they have movable legs at night i never
get that till i fly well this time i
didn't eat marijuana and i [ __ ] got
it dawg
so i was telling one of the air
attendants on the way back and she said
the cabin pressure something is [ __ ]
with my system at night so she goes
don't do it no more then i got off the
[ __ ] plane
the plane is early
i get to the hotel 5 30.
8 30 in the morning i can't [ __ ]
sleep
i can't [ __ ] sleep yeah ruins your
life you got to go outside and smoke 52
joints and i had to go eat breakfast by
the time i fell asleep was nine then
you're walking around at 12 30.
and then you go back to sleep till about
4 30 and then you got to stay up because
the [ __ ] show yeah yeah
you sure that you're like a zombie
you're like a [ __ ] son yeah and i had
great shows i mean they they're cool and
[ __ ] in baltimore they took the ride
i think one night they stiffened up a
little bit and then we started talking
about being blue they were great the
[ __ ]
for st patty's day
i had to do radio and they said the girl
that picked me up at the airport said
i'm picking you up tomorrow
at uh 7 30 in the morning and it's like
a 30 minute ride but afterwards it says
jimmy's seafood
so i thought that i had to go to a
like uh like to meet the owner at a
seafood place like you wanted to buy me
lunch all right and i'm like i'm [ __ ]
too tired you know
let me just go to the hotel and watch
gang land whatever the [ __ ] i watch on
fridays and then i go out or remote or
when they do remote remotes from
restaurants but dog thing that night
everybody was like listen tomorrow
you're doing the remote from jimmy's oh
yeah and they're like wait it make sure
you get the crab cakes like they're the
best best crab cakes in baltimore
i got that guys at 8 45 in the morning
and this place was bumping the bumper
with people
and these people were [ __ ] drinking
and i'm not talking about beers no no no
no yeah like [ __ ] la people like
like drinking beers the waitresses had
[ __ ] things those things
filled with these shots of whiskey and
these people were doing these [ __ ]
shots like they were watering a quarter
tonight willie my soul was hurting like
i hadn't done that in 30 years had a
shot at a quarter of the nine that's
when you feel shitty dog
i shot at a quarter nine but you know
what i mean you know i'm a drinker right
yeah i'm okay with that
oh my god this place was packed and lee
they brought out two crab cakes i
couldn't eat the [ __ ] corned beef and
cabbage because i don't eat meat on
fridays even though the arts diocese
says you could eat meat for saint
patties i said i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
old school
lee if you've seen this
corned beef and cabbage you would have
[ __ ] gave up your religion
when i smelled it my [ __ ] heart
stopped and i didn't eat the guy brought
out two crab cakes they were delicious
i went back to the hotel i smoked some
peppers corned beef guy yeah i'm corned
beef and cabbage how many times a year
do you eat it twice if you're lucky
maybe once yeah i love that [ __ ] i've
always loved it with rye bread and [ __ ]
what
i don't know i mean i never had like a
real legit like my mom made it several
times i had i never went to like a legit
irish place and got it or is it irish is
it an irish dish yeah it is yeah that's
what they give you for saint patty's
there most of those places yeah but this
[ __ ] was money like i smelled that when
i was a kid i used to like corned beef
sandwiches
on rye
tremendous and [ __ ] and so what's going
on willie barcelona right here bro you
chilling with you man always brother you
read this [ __ ] thing say this kid got
charged with 29
felonies
what do you do he's the one that beat up
the the porn star you know oh although
they call him the war machine one
machine oh yeah that was yeah yeah i saw
the uh they were showing his
girlfriend testifying yeah she kind of
stopped but man she she
she got beat up bro you see those
pictures
bro he broke her teeth and [ __ ] i mean
29 felonies jesus christ
and lee was saying that he got away with
four of them that he originally got
charged with 35 of them it was something
like that it was like he got like they
couldn't prove that he wanted to murder
her can you imagine being his attorney i
got good news
i got six felonies dropped okay what's
the bad news you got 29 to deal with 29
35 years old williams so what is he
getting what life was getting life life
yeah well yeah that's what it without uh
uh no he'll never see you no no
no no you know what i gotta give it to
that to that girl man because she was
able to turn that around you know you
know she's she's made t-shirts with
emojis with a with a black eye on it
i don't know if you know about this no
yeah and she's selling it's like she
actually created herself she's created
like a little a cartoon of herself with
a black eye
and and wrote some like you know
something underneath like you know i
i'll survive or like you know
some empowerment thing and she's made uh
some really good cash from that man
that's
you know well i know she donated it a
lot you know she donated a lot i'm
saying it's smart bro
the medical bills were [ __ ]
astronomical with that right
the medical bills were [ __ ] huge man
yeah he [ __ ] her up and
this is just
there's some [ __ ] crazy people out
there you know i wish him i don't know
what to wish him i don't know he's going
right to where you don't come back right
like he's going to
heavy duty what you see not even what
you see on tv
he's going to jail in vegas just like
he's not going where oj is right he's
going somewhere that you might get three
meals a [ __ ] day and you do fight
they don't give a [ __ ] you're in there
for life bro that's the real ufc
his they were saying in the article that
i read that his lawyer's argument was
basically dumbed down to like roid rage
essentially was part of it you me you've
known people who did steroids but they
go crazy when they get like that violent
so
that was the excuse was the the right
that was part of the excuse yeah
oh man
you know brother
some men react different to [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] right okay there's a thousand
lessons out there so okay you know my
philosophy on that bro and here it is
i've i've have buddies that are married
a lot of friends that are married and
this is what i tell them this is what i
tell everybody
look man
if uh
you know if if your chick's gonna [ __ ]
somebody
there ain't nothing in the world you can
do about it man there's nothing in the
world you know what i mean if you're
and chances are your chick is [ __ ]
somebody you know because we're always
busy man we're always on the road i
always talk most of the comics that i
talk to i tell dude trust me you're a
chick [ __ ] somebody
you know what i mean
i mean hey
you know
they need a hug man when we're on the
road someone needs to give him a hug no
i'm just talking about
his [ __ ] question like what
what makes you don't know
listen whenever i go see my mother and i
gotta put flowers in my mother five or
six
five or six graves before there's a kid
named pedro diaz he used to play
basketball with
and when all those marilitos came from
cuba and all that [ __ ] he thought he was
cute and he got a job working for a guy
who's like a bodyguard or some [ __ ] and
he started [ __ ] the guy's wife they
shotgunned them in half
they shotgunned him in half
some people go you did me a favor right
you know what you never know what the
reaction's gonna be
so don't [ __ ] around christy mack is a
beautiful [ __ ] girl she's out she's
you know
they broke up
she's going on moving on with her life
you know what i'm saying she's trying to
put the pieces together
she starts seeing this guy who knows
what went on
and whether she's a porn girl or not he
came in there
i mean
listen if he wanted to kill him
he would have [ __ ] killed him
didn't the guy get away yeah like the
new boyfriend the new boyfriend got away
so
you know if you wanted yo which is
really weird there's a lot of weirdness
here but what he did
nothing
compares to what the [ __ ] he did he went
nuts bro
yeah he went [ __ ] nuts you and og
yeah he went okay
you know didn't he [ __ ] her again and
stuff
after he beat her he did that he was
[ __ ] horrible
so who knows people react to things
differently bro
yeah yeah i mean
like
when you went down and ripped the
ceiling when you get in the coke from
that guy's apartment like is that the
same
thing like no no there was no anger
involved there no okay there's no anger
i was going to get what was mine and my
[ __ ] demented addicted head
there's two different types of lashes
there you know like there's i'm trying
to be a thief i mean dog when i'm a
thief don't get me wrong adrenaline's
pumping your heart's pumping you go deaf
you can hear your heart beat you know
all that same [ __ ] happens
but to walk listen to me
walking breaking the house oh he had a
key didn't he
i don't know that was a while ago i
don't remember that he had a key he went
in there
heard him [ __ ] kicked down the door
and just started beating on him
i knew i didn't i knew a guy like that
uh right out of high school man dig this
you know this guy right out of high
school bro became a copper lapd right
broke up with his broke up with his uh
was an old lady they had like a little
split right
and uh it was here in glendale man and
and uh and he took she started dating
some dude and he came home i guess he
had a couple kids and he told her
um and this is on the la times man this
is all you know i mean you can look this
up
and uh so he tells the guy hey uh listen
this is my wife we just broke up for a
little while just leave
just leave man don't i don't want to see
you again i'm gonna let you i'm gonna
let it go this time but i don't ever
want to come back and see you again so
anyway the guy doesn't take him serious
man and uh and he comes back
like a couple weeks later and the guy's
in his living room sitting there
so
uh
you know this guy who i know real well i
mean i went to junior high in high
school with him
for you know his story goes he puts the
kids
in the closet
and then uh he just starts shooting this
guy man right there but like
you know
like you say bro you never know you know
who it is it's young guys young guys
react because most of the stories you
know old guys bro you know
you know when you're young you think
it's like the it's like the last piece
of [ __ ] you're gonna have in your life
like oh my god you know this is this is
like this pussy's so special you get
older man you're like that lion from the
discovery channel you know how those old
those lions when they fight each other
they fight for the pride and you know
like the old guy loses he doesn't lose
man he's like [ __ ] it man i'm tired of
[ __ ] you know wait till you [ __ ] deal
with [ __ ] take care of these fight
[ __ ]
do you know what i mean as you get older
you're like yeah you don't give a [ __ ]
you like take them bro
wow
i mean what do you think i mean oj was
50.
oj was 50 bro there's no age limit on
this this you don't think so you think
it's rage is great testosterone
rage is right how you listen right the
time with a dude
that was likely
he was mild-mannered he read books he
was a nerd in 1988 right he was
considered nerd the real dudes with the
glasses right right
he said he went home one day
and he could smell it
he wasn't doing any drugs at the time he
said he used to smoke pot cigarettes and
drink
nothing like that this guy was
five foot eight
160.
tiny you know what people consider uh
what what's that not millennials what's
the other ones the one skinny jeans
hipster he was a real hipster like even
in jail right he wore the boots and [ __ ]
you know
and i became friends with him and he
told me a story that he went home one
day
and then he smelt something that he
shouldn't have smelt
because it smelled like a [ __ ] sex
he goes and i asked her questions and i
would see that she was nervous
and he goes i didn't threaten nothing he
goes i just played it i came home early
one day and there she was in bed
i pulled out a gun and shot them both
and here i am
whatever 18 years later
all right that was it he was very cool
man at the bottom he just said they
weren't gonna get away with it did he
say like he blacked out or he did it did
he he walked in with the gun no he
walked in heard them
he goes i didn't even see him he goes i
went and got the gun
i kicked open the door and just shot
them both
yeah man
and he shot him and that's what he said
you know
he knew i was cool and stuff so he goes
he shot him in the head
and the [ __ ] dick or something
and she just went into [ __ ] shock and
he goes
you got three minutes to live or
something [ __ ]
and she started hyperventilating
and he just blasted the rest of the clip
in her hot bro who the [ __ ] no shoot me
in the head first and then the dick can
you [ __ ] i don't want the dick first and
then the head you know what i mean
and then then you can see the thing i
asked him questions like did were you a
violent person before this right and he
was like i never even got into a fist
fight he goes i had guns
to go hunting and i guess whatever he
hunted right you shoot with a gun if
there's a bat i don't know i don't know
nothing about this [ __ ] he was a
colorado boy
so i don't know you know he goes i had
everything in the garage
he goes i just knew something was up i
asked him did he premeditate it
he goes no i just wanted to confront him
so it's [ __ ] a scary thought it's a
[ __ ] scary thought of what you would
do it's a scary thought
not
but i think i think guys start thinking
they own
the girl they're with and i think this
will where we start having problems
because guys start thinking they
actually own that girl and my thing is
you if you put it in your head where you
don't own anybody you know you're like
you just you just don't own another
human being and if that person that
human being uh decides to suck a dick
you know or get laid whatever if you
come from the perspective of i don't own
this person
you know yeah i mean i'm like [ __ ] it
in 1993 i left colorado i took a break
and wanted to take a break i wanted to
get back on my feet
and i really wanted to do comedy
i really wanted to do kind of when i
went to new york city
did i go for it in new york city no i
[ __ ] around like i usually do i got
high
i got on stage a few times in 11 months
but when i went back
to colorado i moved back there with a
puerto rican girl and she was a drug
counselor and then she figured i was
still doing drugs
and i had to move out of her apartment
and i started living at hotels and my
cousins from time to time and i would
sleep in boulder
in that process
i
got
i don't even know i got in contact with
this girl what that was [ __ ] hot when
i was a detailer i used to detail cars
at this place for all these dealerships
and she was the receptionist but i would
always talk to her what's up dog
joey baby she was from somewhere in the
south
but just tremendous
but the general not the general manager
the manager of the detail shop
who was a very nice guy
started dating he had a corvette at that
age you know he started dating it did i
give a [ __ ] no i didn't never said
nothing i had none i didn't even like it
like that i had a girlfriend but at this
time now in 93
him and her had a kid
and she was off the deep end
but really still looking good all right
and she got me a job she goes you want a
job as a car salesman because i do the
books for this place and i help out over
there
so i got a job over there with her and
one day she goes where are you sleeping
until that girl she goes i i can't stay
at my mom's no more so i'm just going to
get a hotel do you want to split the
hotel
and after two nights we got a grandma
coke and sure enough i slept with it
once or twice and
it went on for like a [ __ ] week and a
half and
one day i'm in boulder and who do i bump
into
dog right and he came up to me hey what
are you doing he can i talk to you
like oh yeah what's up he goes listen
man
i talked to her the other day
i know you guys been [ __ ] around he
goes just do me a favor
if you want he goes
i really want to get back together but
she's the mother of my son
and i really want to give it a shot
i don't know how you feel about it
because i don't even know if i should be
saying this to you
i shook his hand
i went over there and got my stuff
i told her what had happened and i never
messed with her again
was i scared of the guy willie not
really
but willie how he came up to me it's a
little scary no no no no
not at all sometimes someone approaches
you oh no no that calm man he's like no
no he was a gentleman in the head okay
he said that he wanted to but he also
wanted her to be happy right and he kind
of had tears in his eyes but he was a
man right he was a man about it he was
sad right you know he didn't trip he was
secure in who he was right i had another
dude that was dating a girl for three
years
somebody came up to me one day and said
listen you guys will make a cute couple
she was talking about it one day
and they were broken up like six months
and i went to this dude like a man and i
said can i talk to you bro how long i
know you right and i said uh
i'm gonna ask you down on the date bro
and i don't want no friction between me
and you and the guy looked at me goes
that's up to you dog but if you do it
there's gonna be a [ __ ] problem okay
now i am gonna [ __ ] it right you know
what i'm saying
so then i did sleep with the [ __ ]
girl and i don't know what happened who
the [ __ ] gives a [ __ ]
but uh that that's that was my take i
liked how he came up to me like a man
right he didn't threaten me at all he
just said he had a kid with it oh he
felt it man no i felt it
this guy's coming from the heart well
what happened was at the time
i had just been was i was yeah oh yeah i
was separated like two years so i know
what it felt like bro yeah i knew what
it felt like we all know what it feels
like to be cheated on we all it's a
horrible [ __ ] feeling you know what
i'm saying that yeah that's why once
you've been cheated on you don't do it
you're like you know what man
i'm gonna check myself in that
department and [ __ ] cuz that [ __ ] would
break my heart if it happened to me so
is it uh that's one of the things i
didn't like about a small town
because like if like in high school if
you just look
you're always gonna know someone who
dated someone else is like the
entertainment industry like the comedy
like the people you guys used to date
was everyone dating everyone or what
could you stick away from stay away from
that
like could you stay away from dating
like another comedian's ex-girlfriend or
i i've never never been put in that
position lee
really i was very fortunate listen man
i looked at comedy a lot different than
a lot of other guys i looked at comedy
as
a savior in a way like it was
don't get me wrong i bumped into
different people now that you mention it
you know what i'm saying like uh
we all know that comedians are dirty
dogs probably we all you know we do some
dirty [ __ ] or whatever so
we you know and most of these comedy
chicks are the same chicks they'll date
you for three years you guys break up
then she starts wearing a bikini going
open mics and [ __ ]
and eventually she's gonna [ __ ] somebody
and you can be tripped about that [ __ ]
oh they just come eating there's nothing
you could do bro
you know those girls have been through
the system they know the [ __ ] deal if
you end up marrying them or whatever and
another thing
because i was in that position
these kind of people that this happens
to 90 of the time
you know when you're with a [ __ ] yeah
whether male or female you know what i'm
saying yeah you know when you're with a
horse so
you have to tolerate i used to date a
[ __ ] heart bro i couldn't trust it
the stripper i moved here with was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] there was nothing until
this day
she's a dirty [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
nothing you could do about it if you
break up with her at three in the
afternoon she'll have a boyfriend by 11
o'clock just on principle just on
principle because that's how she is
that's just the way it is so you know
where you stand nine out of ten times
when you're involved in that situation
and when i say the the word [ __ ] i mean
it is male or female right i'm saying
like you know when you're with a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you catch somebody with a [ __ ]
phone number they give you a story now
you're on high alert
right now you're on high alert
now you catch another story now it's up
to you willie now it's up to you lee now
it's up to me now it's up to you as a
woman
you know the second time you find the
number and there's three hour
discrepancy between here in the store
you know what i'm saying like you went
to rouse it's ten minutes away well what
happened well you're not gonna believe
it they were out of carriage so the guy
said he was gonna go to the other store
and bring him so i said what am i gonna
go home for i just waited for the
carriage and you make up this [ __ ]
tail that guess what willie
we've all listened to and we've all
heard and we want to believe it right we
want to believe it and that's what
happens to people
that's what happens to people you know
i'm lying to you
and then they'll tell somebody like
the girlfriends that the girl will call
and say joey left he's with another
woman
and then that night they'll call him
where was that bendel and he'll say oh
no you're not gonna believe it he went
to rouse he got rear-ended
the engine went on fire the fire
department had to come his cell phone
fell in the water
but when he got home we put it in rice
and everything's okay enough
you know you believe what the [ __ ] you
want to believe when you're in love you
know
and especially there's two types of love
see the stripper i was never in love
with it was that [ __ ] all right
it was that filthiness infatuated that
filthiness that she would do i had never
i was married for [ __ ] six years
seven years
and they don't let you light that [ __ ]
on fire and put [ __ ] chocolate in
that [ __ ] nobody what i'm saying so you
know i put bottles in this girl's [ __ ]
who doesn't what she does i was
infatuated with the thought of somebody
else doing this thought
and then one day i looked like how many
dicks could possibly be in i want to
marry this [ __ ] monster
i want to marry this [ __ ] monster and
do what
and do what
and do what i got a cdd the kids what's
that [ __ ] when you got to send in an
anarchy test
what is that [ __ ] when to see who the
father is [ __ ]
that's what i want to worry about this
is this is this yellow kid my father
why does he have blonde hair i'm not you
know i didn't want to worry about that
so you [ __ ] move on with your life
and that's when people that's a lot of
people say i started to get stand up
comedy because when i moved here the
first two years in 97 and 98
60 percent of my focus was on that broad
50 percent of my focus was dissecting
her stories
you know 50 percent of the story the
other the other but there's another
moral to the story here she was paying
the rent
yeah that helps and she was tripping so
you know i'm saying like there was all
these things that i didn't need to be
there but because i was struggling to be
a comic i was putting up with them
because it was the ultimate goal and in
a lot of ways today i thank her because
she got me to like
she got me to l.a you know what i'm
saying let's be honest no matter what
happened between us
she got me that way she was put in my
life for a purpose that dirty [ __ ]
god put it in my life for a purpose you
know what i'm saying all right
i like the way god got you gotta got you
some dirty [ __ ]
who else would play a dirty trick on you
like that i'd say hey i'm gonna get joy
some dirty [ __ ] man no that [ __ ] sucks
it's always been a
a checkpoint
for me like listen
my ex-wife in boulder
she cheated on me
at the time i didn't know right but now
today after thinking about it
i didn't see it i didn't see it at the
age of 32 or whatever [ __ ] old that
was
i saw it maybe
10 years ago one day just went because
when i went to jail he went in there for
a haircut and he sent her flowers
and when they were visiting and she goes
let me tell you the story some guy came
in and sent me flowers
but he kept going in there for haircuts
after that do you understand me
and eventually he caught her when me and
her weren't doing too good
and then she came to me and she goes
we're gonna separate
i'm gonna move in with my parents and
that weekend i couldn't get a hold of
her and she told me she went away you
know i'm saying where the [ __ ] did you
go would you go away
so now today i believed it now today
after
separating myself from the emotion i was
like that's where she went all right and
then you know she we [ __ ] uh broke up
october 15th she moved in before
christmas
no she wasn't [ __ ] she was just
living on the couch what are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] so
that's the way life is that's the way
life goes [ __ ] tick tock
tick tock what comes around goes around
[ __ ] that's right that's right
you know i listen i got a friend of mine
another dude who this guy was a player
bro i mean player hands a handsome guy
man a fireman you know and this guy had
[ __ ] everywhere bro this guy had like
just everywhere he went you know good
looking guy
you know anyways uh
buses old lady [ __ ] somebody right
this guy goes nuts man
he busted you know one with one dick
he's had like a thousand [ __ ] and he
busted one dick and he goes nuts
and uh literally uh
how to get therapy and all that and then
everybody's like [ __ ] wrong with you
man you know you're like you're like the
washington generals man you know the
you lost one
you know you know harlem globetrotters
well a thousand you know you gotta give
the washington generals one yeah
his ego got in the way yeah i couldn't
[ __ ] believe somebody would do it
with him but what comes around goes
around bro women know when we cheat on
them
women know they're not stupid
they're not [ __ ] stupid at all
and you got to be a you know the other
day lee and i were talking about a
subject real [ __ ] up like
we were talking about
a friend of mine
that was a holder
and he was telling me a story once that
for four years he just paid this chicks
right and he'd go over there whenever he
wanted and just [ __ ] her once a week he
didn't care if she had a relationship
right and then i started hearing it more
and more and more
you know
his head blew up because i was 30 when i
heard about it like i had never heard
about something like that i knew people
giving you money for a piece of [ __ ]
but i i never heard about guys just
paying your bills
making your car payment paying your rent
and giving you a thousand bucks a month
but listen here's the deal
when i call you ten minutes later i'm
showing up and you're swallowing dick
you're taking in the ass i'm lighting
you on fire
there's no questions you know what i'm
saying i'm [ __ ] you without a condom
i don't give a [ __ ] if you got a
boyfriend or not i'm sticking my big
yonker and your little monkey you know
i was blown away willie
i was blown
away they got websites
they got websites where just dudes
will take care of you
up you know sugardaddy.com probably
let's see it listen
i want to see sugar daddy
i know they have cougar
let's see if they have
that was something the first time i
heard that willie like the first time i
heard that i was 30. i had already
thought i had heard everything first
time i heard that i could not [ __ ]
believe it
and then i started thinking about it
over the years and i go oh i get it now
it's as [ __ ]
discreet as can be
and the chicks who do it i guess do it
all the time they got a couple [ __ ]
sugar daddies yeah they just keep
getting cars and [ __ ] this is crazy i
never especially in l.a man a lot of
them come here and they're good looking
they're hot they used to be a comedian
at the store they used to be a comedian
at the store
lee that he bought in fake tits
she had a convertible mercedes
a yellow one he had him in a
penthouse when i used to go to acting
class there was a black girl
that lived right next to shaq
what the [ __ ] does it say there
so the number one site is
sugardaddymeat.com i hope you ladies
have your pens out
uh it's the best choice if you're
looking for a sugar daddy or sugar baby
love in relationship
jesus christ i told you bro
this was a millionaire match.com
seems like a good one
jesus seeking arrangement
sugar daddy for me
dot com so this [ __ ] this week's yoga
daddy
yeah
and these cats man they're like uh
you know they
they make money they don't have time to
go romance anybody
and uh
and
and it's like you said you know they're
there for when you need them
think then get lost you know
jesus
i wonder what it would cost you to sign
up and [ __ ] just to [ __ ] with a bunch of
chicks
tell them i got like 10 million dollars
they probably have a voting process you
could probably get on
a sugar no it's a sugar baby that's the
girl
i am what let's see
you're sugar daddy seeking a
sugar baby
now don't be putting my birthday in
there i'm not i don't yeah i'm not gonna
do that
but now you gotta give him an email
oh yeah you're [ __ ] yeah don't worry
about it no i just want to see what they
would how much you got to pay these
[ __ ] animals
oh my god
828 000 wealthy sugar daddies
106 beautiful sugar babies yeah six
hundred thousand you bet your ass
there's a lot more giving than getting
wealthy sugar daddies and young
beautiful [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
perhaps no and and they're only perhaps
taking care of you financially that's
how they get away with it perhaps
oh my gosh certified daddy's first day
gift
they got engaged
what the [ __ ]
oh my god man just get up just get a
hooker bro you can meet sugar daddy's in
van nuys right now
let's go over there lee see who shows up
little chubby dude with a wig and [ __ ]
owns a club in kansas city
i can't believe you bro you didn't know
the dude in kansas city had to wait no
bro we were talking about that uh uh
before because the guy who owns the
comedy club
that's not a i still can't believe it's
a weird it's a skunk bro never died and
when he does coke
it crank you can hear it crinkling up
the glue [ __ ] [ __ ] up from the sweat
there's two dudes i knew like that the
dude from icm
yeah which
he was married to the comedian chick she
disappeared
anybody from icm he she always opened
number four he's got a wig and soda's
[ __ ] uh
uh
what's his name
what's his name oh man i forget the
dude's name you should start a new blog
joey what the wigs of hollywood no i
don't give a [ __ ] pretty soon i'm gonna
have a wig a little no you're not sure
i'm thinking of shaving it off and you
just get the tube to [ __ ] with people
saying
[Music]
hey somebody just told me that that guy
the the gm from the dodgers has a wig
i don't know coletta khalida letter you
guys know that somebody goes
i couldn't tell and i go to my i asked
my god how do you know he goes dude i'm
bald i know wigs
because i know that's a wig bald guys
know
that's cheating
my god i didn't know there was a [ __ ]
website for that
but it makes sense people just now
what's the other one that they gave away
the phone numbers ashley madison now
what's that that's for uh just anyone
who wants to cheat i'm sure i'm sure
there they have that under it but
it's that that's for like anyone who
wants to have like a an affair that's
that's their big thing and you meet them
online
yeah which doesn't make sense at all to
me no it doesn't make sense to me that's
why i didn't know i didn't [ __ ]
like that i mean
i i've never cheated but to just
whenever i see like this like these
athletes get coming out and they have
like these huge long text things with
girls
i'm like how you can't at all
we'll talk your way out of that like at
all you can't so like i don't like like
no other when they say there's a thing
now talking in dms i don't
i don't dm with any girls like i don't
like i don't say hi to dm uh direct
messaging on twitter on anything for
twitter facebook so they follow you on
there like anyone yeah any girls anyone
who follows you can dm you but it just
like so you don't answer them because
you know that leads to something well
hey there's like 97 mail listening to
this
um
but well not that high but no i mean i
answer some of them but i don't like i
don't flirt at all like it's just i
don't want i don't want any sort of
weirdness
i i don't want any
why don't you just go shoot yourself
you're 28 [ __ ] years old and you
don't want no type of weirdness you want
to sit in the house every night and
watch boxing wreck
and [ __ ] that's what you want to do
die in there five nights a week
thank god i get you out of here [ __ ]
you know thank god i get you out of the
house two nights and you go down there
one night to play cards if not you'd
melt into that [ __ ] couch well i know
i mean if i was single it would be
different but like at home i don't what
are you scared of living a little bit i
don't well no no you gotta live a little
bit what the [ __ ] she wants to meet you
say hello lee maybe she'll send you a
picture that little monkey first of all
it's not like i'm getting hit up like
let me let me suck your dick like that
a girl hits you up you got to hit him
back and say no i always say hi
when you're single you're single no he
got himself into a [ __ ] predicament
he moves her in
28. now he's over there every night
sitting on the couch
sniffing his own feet and [ __ ]
eating blue apron at night [ __ ] you
know
you don't even see him no more
is your first serious uh for serious
girlfriend lee
uh yeah pretty serious like the first
pretty serious one yeah the first one
i'm live with
you gotta live a little bit and let them
see
that [ __ ] and
you could whack off when your wife's in
the shower and do different things you
know what i'm saying if you're gonna be
a monk already at 28. can you imagine
you're 40 you're going to be dead i'm
not going to be a monster but i don't
want to like i don't want like my
biggest fear is to like have to worry
about where i left my cell phone like
it's bull look at that don't know what
what's wrong with that because i don't
want to have to think about that oh like
sometimes what if someone's uh what if
she's looking at the directions and then
i get a text with a [ __ ] picture i
don't want that one why don't you look
in the direction don't you have her own
[ __ ] phone who cares it's a phone and
you know what i'm telling you bro
cheating today
you you got to be slick man like in our
days you just you got a number you got a
napkin you tore it up threw it away now
that now there's too much uh you know
there's uh you know i mean it's a
detroit paper trail it's a [ __ ] too
much paper dress there's a trail for no
reason
but we didn't have that we didn't have
that no reason
no reason there's two girls came up to
me in baltimore and they have a podcast
dick pics or something because they both
got sick and tired of all the pictures
of dicks they got let me tell you
something
i can live to be a thousand i won't send
you a picture of my dick
i'll show you my nutsack all day long
i'll put it on album covers i'll do the
whole [ __ ] thing
but there's no way i would send you a
picture of my [ __ ] not at this age it's
just
embarrassing it's just [ __ ]
embarrassing to me was that a thing
before digital cameras like when you
were young like a picture you know
you had polaroids
with a polaroid you took a picture of
your dickens and put a thumbtack on her
daughter and [ __ ] and [ __ ] rang the
ball around like a [ __ ]
you know
though you know how hard it was like
i had friends that used to have
polaroids all the time i thought they
were [ __ ] disgusting
first off the photography it wasn't hd
in those days like this red brick would
have shined on the [ __ ]
oh my god i had a friend that every time
i went to his house he showed me [ __ ]
pictures
of the chicks he was [ __ ] with
polaroids
puerto rican nelson too
he always had all the pictures of chicks
he was [ __ ] with polaroids i always
thought that was the most disgusting
[ __ ] thing ever
and you go to the house and they'd have
stack of pictures lee
in those days of all the women they [ __ ]
with polaroids like who would let you
take a [ __ ] picture of them
i'll let you take a picture of my dick
but i'm i'm leaving with that picture
i'm taking the [ __ ] film and then
yeah and what if you're not at your
house like that you know are they
walking around with the polaroid camera
would people walk around with that no
everybody had them in their house in
those days that was for the quick pick
that was for the quick pick of the
snatch or the
patois whatever you were a pig
but i'm telling you it was
oh people always show up with [ __ ]
that's the way people would have
pictures on their phones and have
polaroids in the jacket pocket come here
let me show you what happened thursday
night
how long would you carry the same
pictures around for years these guys are
[ __ ] perverts
you know um i have a buddy that uh this
guy uh he's been caught a few times
and uh check this
so he he didn't want he's his wife told
him look
i'm not playing any games with you this
chick would sniff his underwears his
wife would
would sniff him to see if he's been
[ __ ] around
right and he was [ __ ] around this one
night you know what this dude did bro so
his chick wouldn't sniff his underwear
he crapped his pants man
he [ __ ] on himself
so he ran home
and his and then he told his wife
like can you believe i crapped myself
and she was laughing at him and he goes
bro she laughed her ass off but she
never smelled my underwear that night
i gotta tell you bro let me if that was
one of the coolest moves i've ever heard
in my life at what point
do you look at your relationship you
know what man
this chick is sniffing my underwear when
i come home but this is to the point in
my life where i'm living where at night
when i'm on the [ __ ] sleeping when
i'm on the bed sleeping she tiptoes up
and it's just my [ __ ] underwear
that's a bad [ __ ] relationship right
there yeah that's bad man [ __ ]
hilarious you gotta admit man yeah no
you know that was creative oh my god
do you think they're still just going
back to the polaroids do you think
there's a one guy from that era who
still has some polaroids thousands
there's an old guy
somewhere with [ __ ] boxes of naked
women bro
boxes of naked women oh my god that they
don't even know they have with harry
with harry
my roommate in boulder he's a polaroid
guy he had
stacks of them going back to the [ __ ]
70s to the mid 70s oh my god like
[ __ ] college and [ __ ] lee you just
take you've seen the the um playboys
from the 70s right yeah have you seen
they're hairier than your face bro
that back back then there was no
trimming
[ __ ] we've never even heard of trimming
remember i mean i never heard of that
and then in the 70s and not even the 80s
well i didn't see a [ __ ] till the 80s
at that point they were still hairy and
tropical and nobody brazilian wax nobody
was ill nothing in the summertime they
would shave like i knew a couple girls
that were young
and then i would go swimming with them
and they didn't even know they had to
shave like
the sides of their legs
legs yeah they would still have i would
go crazy and there was no thongs bro
yeah i was normal
when i was a kid if you had bush
sticking out of your bikini
my head would blow up brad would just
come in my bathing suit it was just it
was sexy it was sexy dog and you'd see
it lee
all the time you go to the beach and you
just stay in the shallow water and wait
for the [ __ ] waves to hit girls and
they'd stand up and their [ __ ] thing
the [ __ ] it looked like a little afro
would come out of the sides they had
tons of hair
where did we where did it switch up to
to
to trimming it to shaving it
trimming it you know whatever i trimmed
my nuts now i got sick and tired of
scratching the hair gets dry
and you start they get itchy and so i
had to start [ __ ] trimming like a
design that you like no yeah i put like
a diamond
nothing i hold on to my dick and i tell
my wife to shave around it with the
electric shaver and she trims it all
down nice and i put powder on it
everybody's a jewish star or something
no i ain't got time for that well you
know why would i do something like that
i'm 54 years old have some fun with your
life what else do you get some giggles
because i've already had plenty of
giggles lee it's not me i'm worried
about it
you're 28 at 28 i wasn't even sleeping
at night i was like an upside down
[ __ ] vampire
you're 20 and they call you at seven
o'clock hey we're cooking
we're having a good time what [ __ ]
good time you're 28 in the house
go on a chat chip line and see what 28
year olds are doing right now they're
not at home watching [ __ ] season
eight of parks and rec for the 80th time
you know yeah i'm having a good time
aren't you yeah
let's talk okay what do you want to talk
about
i don't know there's a lot of 28 year
olds on chat lines anymore i feel like
you feel like
i don't know i feel like a two thousand
what two thousand cause i tell you
you're an amateur you're trying to lie
and say oh my god i ate two thousand
i saw you double up you ate a thousand
how dare you i saw you double up i did
not double yes you did this is why you
get so [ __ ] up tonight i'm not [ __ ]
up i called you sadly when you ate 2 000
you weren't [ __ ] up and look at that
thousand [ __ ] bro he's in training he's
listen you know i i i just recently
started smoking weed like like within
the last month and i haven't made you
smoke weed okay i'm traveling on the
road with these uh young comedians
and
believe it or not man they're worried
about my health because you know i love
to drink tequila bro i don't [ __ ] around
there's a guy that'll take a shot two
shots i can take eight nine shots bro
and i'm you know i'm smooth but they're
they're like man willie you know if you
want to live longer and i know it man
you know
you know i know that that weed's more
conducive to your body and all that but
the thing is that i'm that's not
something that i that i was you know
what i blame my uncles man i was raised
with these uncles when i was a kid and
and they would play cards you know and
they would uh and i was like eight nine
years old and i would go get beer and
they'd play poker
you know and they would always tell me
like you know uh
you know then they drink a beer you know
or give me a sip of beer so i always
thought that marijuana was for like it
was like crack see they had they had
programmed me to think that marijuana
was cracked man
and and obviously we get older we
realized you know a lot of my uncles are
dead i mean more than half of them are
dead
because of alcohol so anyway so these
kids right these young comedians i go on
the road with man they're like uh hey
willy you got us and they all take i
don't know how they do it but they get
weed everywhere we go every city illegal
city cities you're not supposed to have
weed you want you'll go to jail for 20
years don't get it get it we got it
they gave me i brought i was telling you
man they gave me my first edible uh you
said 2 000 milligrams right yeah no one
takes that amount
man i took a 150 and and i couldn't for
your first time yeah
i couldn't i couldn't move my arms and
the weird thing is i don't know why this
happened i don't know where what part of
the subconsciousness comes from it
doesn't happen never it's never happened
when i've been drunk but i couldn't move
and i started thinking that the kid was
gonna rape me
i don't know why
i don't know where that comes from you
know i mean i'm sure that did you pass
out how long did it hurt no i didn't
okay i did pass out after a while man
after after like um
you know an hour into it because they
gave me an edible and then they also
gave me which i'm learning i mean i know
you guys are pros but i'm learning i
feel like a [ __ ] baby here that the
hype hybrid hybrid uh
i bring weed yeah and and then so i had
him explain to me what it was and then
it's basically like
two different you get this type of weed
that type of weed they [ __ ] each other
and then they have like different type
of like weed babies right right so
they're giving me that and uh
anyways bro
yeah i i got uh
you know and then i can't sleep i have
trouble sleeping and there's another
reason they recommended this no this is
the best if you can't yeah there's
nothing better than this yeah so there
is melatonin after three days
it wears out but with reefer you could
smoke one night take a piece of
something one night
smoke one night take a piece of
something one night the other night
smoke something different yeah so your
body never can become you have to trick
your body just like working out drink
your body trick your body isn't sure
right you know the reason why lee eats
2 000 milligrams of stars is because
we've been eating them for a year and a
half
and
two i can eat 2 000 milligrams and three
hours later nothing happens to me
this is why i gave them up for length
because i wanted my body to take a break
from
if we start i tomorrow i could go to a
store
and by now there's got to be a new
edible that's 500 milligrams
me and we'll bring here that here eat it
and we'll get us more [ __ ] up than the
2000 milligrams
we ate tonight because our body's not
used to that one right we'll get [ __ ]
anxiety we won't be able to breathe
your body builds up a tolerance
tolerance yeah you build up a [ __ ]
tolerance man right you know and and i
and
people always say how do you smoke the
way you do
because in 1983 i was smoking out of a
three-foot bong in colorado
in the altitude oh so that made my lungs
stretch you know what i'm saying yeah my
lungs are damaged now i'm not proud of
this
you know i'm not but there's nothing but
they're not damaged like if you would
have smoked a cigarette
but i smoked for 10 years so i have
the beginnings of that [ __ ] right your
lungs reach for air right that disease
where if i would have kept smoking the
way i would and the reefer i would have
killed them it's really hard to repair
the lungs yeah you could stop smoking
like the liver it's but it takes time to
take a certain vitamin supposedly i read
i don't even know if the vitamins is
true
how did a good friend of ours just died
from alcohol
just two weeks ago
44 years old bro yeah
i don't know man i i always say joey
like the the only thing
my father ever left me
was a good liver man that's i i believe
that that's the only how easy when you
started drinking oh man i don't know 18
19.
do you give it breaks
no
you go every night or just one on the
road ah just on on the road what's on
the road yeah man
and but but you know my dad used to
drink our cologne bro
like when my my mom would hide the
alcohol he would drink the cologne
and when when she when he couldn't find
the cologne he would drink the rubbing
alcohol
you know
so i feel
that that that that's the gift he gave
me he gave me a good [ __ ] liver bro
it's like you know what i mean
he gave me something bro i don't
understand the
your uncles that died what diseases did
they die from most of them are
alcoholism
and you know and they go little by
little they don't just go
you know it's the diabetes and then you
know they lose a foot
and then a leg
and then they're
isolated and even when they get to
diabetes they keep drinking they keep
yeah i remember i had i had an uncle man
that uh
they they and he was one of my favorite
uncles man and i i is a good dude but uh
i remember uh by the way this guy was a
player bro my uncle
was i remember in the 70s man i'm going
to tell you something in the 70s he used
to take me with him
and and and i used to wait in the car
you know i was supposed to be out doing
things with him but he would take me and
i would sit in the car i remember the
hot summer [ __ ] days man while he'd
go and bang some some some brat right
and then he'd get back in the car and
then go hey you know just tell me we saw
chinese connection you know that kind of
[ __ ]
but he didn't he would never take me uh
uh uh to the movies or where wherever i
was supposed to go
but this guy was a player he wore he
wore that that that big tall or that
that leather jacket remember they would
wear them even in the summer long ones
yeah even in the summer and he had the
long the long uh uh freddy fender
hair you know back in the center those
those are my uncles man those those type
of cats so check this out man and my
aunt would be mad as [ __ ] i remember she
would get mad at him because he wouldn't
come home and
bro as my uncle got old uh you know
um he lost a leg and then and and but he
wouldn't stop drinking and then and then
he would watch television but he had to
be two inches away from it
i remember one time um i came home
i came i went to go visit him and he was
screaming man he was going hey
i could hear somebody screaming from the
backyard hey hey
right and i go what the hell so i go i
go to the backyard and it's my uncle in
his wheelchair he's up against the ivy
up against and i go what's going on he
goes that's your hat she [ __ ] put me
here right i'm like what the [ __ ] so i
get them out put them in the house and i
tell my my aunt hey you you know marco
was uh in the bushes and she goes yeah
[ __ ] him you know cause like now she got
even
you know 20 35 years later she's not
like [ __ ] you
i'm the boss yeah man so i gotta you
know i got a billy night that's gonna be
me bro
yeah i can't
i've always been like i had a friend
growing up that when he was like 20 they
told him to stop drinking guess what
he's still drinking he's still alive bro
so where's tony bennett [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i wanna be around
to
pick up the pieces
get it together somebody you better read
that [ __ ] book again the war of art
you're slipping and [ __ ]
i'll read it again
and then they they robbed the joint yeah
yeah he does the same
because when i called him that night
after the 2000 milligrams he he wasn't
high at all tonight he eats 2 000. he's
half more mode up
the whole [ __ ] deal look at him he
thinks he's like he does that trick that
drinkers do the guys that can't what
they do is they drop their they drop the
shot yeah
they dropped it so he puts in his mouth
and drops it in his hand
and he only puts it ten times
five stars i watched him you did one of
these dear daily you took this no i
didn't know you dropped it into your
hand and you may believe you swallowed
so what are you going to do now
you got the weekend this weekend that
i'm at the uh yeah at the ice house
brother
saturday night you're taping a special
and you were saying that
you're going to produce it 100 yourself
that's it you're not [ __ ] around
who's shooting it yeah um a young film
uh a filmmaker named michael martinez uh
his kid graduated from ucla film school
and sharp man this guy just knows you
know knows his deal man
and uh i'm just doing it all man you
know
everything six cameras three cameras
yeah man and we got the four 4k
you know really really sharp cameras and
i i want to own my own project
joey you know this is my fourth special
and man i you know i i see nickels and
dimes from my my other specials and i
want to be able to say i own a property
like i own this and i want to make a
deal and
and i know i know that people have said
yeah there's some cats that have done
their own project but nobody's bought
them i've heard that but i know how much
work i put into it no you could sell it
my standard
and every time i get deeper and deeper
as i get older and wiser i'm able uh to
talk more and adapt the bot
but you know [ __ ] that bothered me in my
life
so
i guess the for me
i know the comedy's a little richer you
know if you look at a joke i did if you
look at my jokes from uh from like early
tonight shows
they're more jokey jokes and you can see
the you can almost see the like my jokes
growing as like like babies you know
they went from like like barely crawling
to walking you know what i mean
yeah that kind of thing so now i'm so
i'm excited about this special man i i i
i i get a little deeper about a lot of
things
you know race i get i look up deeper
about what uh how i feel about uh
religion you know a little a little
deeper about you know uh being with my
wife 24 years and and being more honest
about about the [ __ ] that we go through
so yeah man as it's uh
like i said i'm excited and and uh the
last time i did a show at the ice house
i wasn't filming but i was here with you
bro and
man a lot of your
your fans
came out and and they showed love and
they said
because you you know
man you know you
you know it says something when you when
you say something bro is that kind of
you're like oh i don't [ __ ] around
you're like you're like that commercial
e of hutton yeah you never heard it
listen i'm not gonna put a comic in on
the show i get hit up by a lot of people
man
and
i've made mistakes with comics and put
them on here maybe not
but i want
people to open their eyes to the guys i
put out here i think i
and i don't know why the reason i know
your reason i know your reason because
you've been here with me since day one
and you keep going and you keep going
nothing bothers you boom you've had the
best managers and you had the worst
money right you had the best agents and
you've had the worst agents just like me
right right this is a [ __ ] journey
that's
and by now most of the people
got off the journey like
i wake up every morning i'm like how
fortunate am i that
there was people who came to this town
got half a million dollar deals right
going to be stars they would walk into
the store with this attitude with this
cavalier [ __ ] attitude
the deal didn't work out and they
fizzled away because they were never
really stand-ups to start off with yeah
well a lot of them just stand up for
just for the deal just for the deal yeah
yeah yeah they didn't do it for the love
you know what it really like you see
through it it hurts your feelings when a
guy disappears and
what happened you know right so to see
real comments that go through the bad
times the good times the medium times
and i went through all of them right
i've been through all of them the bad
you know the other morning i woke up
and somebody had asked me if i did black
rooms no i'm not racist
but i'm i can't work for a black pomona
because you know what happens sometimes
you don't get paid do you remember the
time that guy ran out on the [ __ ] dj
and they were waking us up in the middle
of the night
oh no he ran on the radio station
the radio station woke me up a foreign
have you seen him i forget what the
guy's name was he says he was the tour
manager of earth when the fire
and he would book me and a bunch of
other morons and bring a castle made of
rubber and call us the latin kings or
the latin something else with comedy and
there was always a disgrace discrepancy
every [ __ ] night after the show or
they say this this is this is a famous
line because i heard this uh
probably 50 times
look man
work with me brother yeah
let me holler at you
the ticket sales weren't good that
[ __ ] was back
yeah but i had to give away 400 tickets
at the radio promotion and you're
sitting there going jesus [ __ ] christ
and you know this isn't a racist
statement this is not i don't want
people to think this is a racist
statement there's a lot of i used to
work in beaumont texas yeah white guy
white guys latinos they they've all
[ __ ] me bro oh yeah no i've been
[ __ ]
nationality yeah but the funniest ones
have been black people except there was
a black young couple they were engineers
and i don't know if you remember they
all they owned the first comedy club in
beaumont
this is 20 years ago the first time i
worked and i i featured for ralphie
somebody had fell out during the week
and i had a feature for ralphie and they
were a great black couple they were
great people they put you at a great
hotel they brought food in on saturday
night but i started at a black club in
denver yeah i started a black club here
yeah which one i started the comedy act
theater what's the guy's name uh michael
williams
michael and sharon williams they were
brother and sister but what was the name
of the guy that used to do the the
comedy show there from do the right
thing sweet dick willie oh baby's kids
oh oh robin williams no
something robin harris robin robin
williams robin harris man because yeah
because when rob i got there when robin
harris uh uh uh died like like he had
died a couple of months and then dial
higgly took it over
you know back and then man bro back in
those days i used to give chris tucker a
ride to the comedy act theater
he lived in an apartment up here near
near and a couple of miles uh
up north from where where we're at right
now really chris tucker yeah check this
out bro you know when i used to pick him
up
he had a uh went in his
in his apartment all he had was a a bed
but a bed on the floor all right
and he had a he had a milk crate and on
top of the milk crate he had a [ __ ] up
tv but on top of the tv
he had a picture of himself like just
like
just a picture of himself with his two
fingers pointing pointing out and i
remember asking chris i go chris
why do you have a picture yourself like
i didn't get it and he says you know why
because i'm beautiful man i'm great he
would tell me how great he was and at
this time you got to understand he only
had five minutes of material bro but as
i got older
and and you read and you and and i
understood now wow man
you see the reason you can't have other
people like love you like actually
believe in who you are until you
you love who you are and and that's what
we really use
and i didn't know that i don't even
think chris knew what he was doing but
he was just
you know it was just natural for him
to uh to just say man i'm beautiful man
you know how you talk back in the day
this was pre-friday oh it's pretty fine
oh yeah no yeah bro i used to take him
to mcdonald's he would call me up
he didn't have a car
most time he didn't have money and i
would take him to mcdonald's and uh and
buy him a buy him a burger man you know
back in the day back in those days who
else uh uh
um
guy tori
you know joe torre
pierre came on that movie with halle
berry
uh uh man who's all those all those cats
man
what's up lee
i'm doing okay
trying to tell me two thousand on seven
what i did you didn't look like that on
saturday what why is that you didn't see
me on saturday night
all right put your words together bro
i called you on saturday i could tell
you weren't this [ __ ] high
trying to con me and the american public
and telling us you're doing two thousand
when you're doing a thousand so i'm
saying together i would never do that to
any any public it don't seem like great
[ __ ] days i you would i remember one
night at that
club by the car dealership you were
telling me about picking them up in the
valley i'm like jesus [ __ ] christ
and how he got somebody was telling me
how you got friday right they saw him at
the store or something like that yeah
yeah what the big thing was from the
he did def jam the fjm really blew him
up he did five minutes on def jam and
that was it man
just shot
you know i remember back i remember i
remember his joke from back in those
days
one of chris
chris tucker's early jokes is like hey
man
uh if anybody ever robbed me he'd just
be practicing
that was his big
big joke back in the day man
but uh yeah man he's a
he was a good dude and when i when i see
him and he's you know what i like about
chris he's still still a cool
solid dude you know he's always had his
feet on the ground because we know bro
you know you know joey we've we've been
around with guys you know like like you
said right now they're guys that that
fizzled right but we also know cats that
that [ __ ] oh my god to the moon
that aren't the same [ __ ] guys no no
no no you're like hey [ __ ] i
remember you no i remember i remember
[ __ ]
you know
nothing bothers you more than that yeah
you see some like there's people who are
your acquaintances that blow up that's
one thing
yeah that's one thing when there you're
quite hey man how you then you see them
and you're actually happy for them they
never did nothing to you
but then there's people that you kind of
knew that yeah part took with you know
at one time
maybe one day you went to his house for
christmas
and there's one day you see him and they
just say no yeah like that's it like i'm
a different person now i really don't
want it and you're like
okay right
that's that's a that's a really [ __ ]
up feeling man and i've heard it's
happened to a lot of people like even in
the acting community right like even in
the acting community they all went to
acting class together in one day people
actually have that conversation they
actually say
i don't i don't want to be your friend
anymore
ah
no but
like i heard a great
like i knew a guy and and i had done a
couple of projects with him he's an
italian guy
and he had some great credits this guy
but when i met him i could tell there
was something not right he was a little
too goofy
and then he signed me up for something
one day and it wasn't what he said
happened i was embarrassed and [ __ ]
and i could tell by his choices that it
was just [ __ ] up but one day he was
telling me he showed me something
i had to go rehearse with him or
something and we started i had to pick
him up
and he just come in for a second and
when i was walking out there was a
picture of him
like bro nick nolte um uh some other
dude names gandalfini all right like
there was just like eight actors and a
bunch of girls at like a lakeside bar
and i go what's this holy [ __ ]
that's like [ __ ] gandafini and like
[ __ ] whatever and he goes let me tell
you a story
he goes
before gandafini got the movie with
denzel
on the boat
with gene hackman
he goes we were great friends he goes in
those days what you would do is you
would audition all week
and then on saturdays you went to marina
del rey that's what this place was you
know coke all weekend and you drink and
bang chicks right
and he goes bro for [ __ ]
two or three years i mean he goes from
that movie
to this movie i don't know what movies
exactly right he goes gandolfini hung
out down
he goes i have to get shorty
something happened he moved to the
valley or
something really [ __ ] weird i don't
know the whole story but i've heard a
lot of weird stories right like i know a
guy right now
but i still see him once a month at the
coffee shop this guy was a big time
agent gay as [ __ ]
good guy good guy and he tells me
that he's good friends
with somebody who had a child with
gandafini off the record like she never
you know
but this is hopeful you know yeah you
don't know who the [ __ ] to believe right
but this dude i've heard the story about
this dude to be true and he's dead now
but he was showing me these pictures and
he goes let me tell you the funny thing
this went on for like two maybe three
years
you know we get together and we'd snort
all these guys nick nolte he goes they
would just come to this bar and then
we'd go to a house right and we party
all weekend long and he goes i still
remember
that gandafini stopped coming around
but he caught he goes after the sopranos
first season
he goes i'm a big mob type the guy was a
big mafia worker
he goes i actually called him i still
had his number he goes and he answered
and i go jimmy this is
how you doing i want to congratulate you
on your success and he goes yeah yeah
yeah
and he goes uh listen the reason why i
called is because maybe there's a role
for me on the sopranos and he goes
listen
i'm gonna be honest with you that stuff
we were doing that was a long time ago
oh
you know i really you know
but you know he made defeat look like a
bad guy like one of those hollywood
actors you know what i'm saying yeah and
i remember caught i remember i did a
movie
with the dude that was junior's
bodyguard season one
and he was friends
the movement and i told him that story
and he goes bro he goes i know exactly
who that guy is
he goes that guy was a [ __ ] pain he
has you know like he was just one of
those guys that was a hanger on see
there's a story to everything right you
know people i had spoken to always said
gandalfini helped everybody you know he
was just a great guy he fought for
people he gave the money on the set that
they times they gave him a raise he gave
everybody a raise
so when he told me the story i was like
i don't know guy this don't sound like
this guy
and that this guy from this uh sopranos
confirmed he goes bro i know that dude
too because i party with that [ __ ]
dude too he goes he didn't stop
bothering gandalfini
he goes he called him from the minute he
heard he shot a pilot for the mafia he
started calling and blowing up his
[ __ ] phone yeah and i guess one day
jimmy finally answered the phone and
said don't call no more bro right you
know right
what well you know listen i'll tell you
a good story to this right when we're
talking about cats with that with that
vibe you you know emilio right emilio
rivera yeah yeah he's he was on the uh
sons of john
you know he's he's uh i knew him from
back in the day
you know
yeah and now they're he's the the lead
on the new mayans
uh and and uh and he's just down to
earth man i invited him to the
uh to the special uh this weekend
and and he's just down the earth man he
goes willie a man i'm dude i'm a big fan
i'll support you i'm there you know what
i mean you can tell it's just the same
it's the same
emilio from when we used to do that room
in east l.a you know uh tortillas and uh
these guys three times oh you've had
amelia oh my god he's really my favorite
he's full-time bro he's the real deal
a lot of people don't know he's the real
a lot of people don't know he's the real
deal when it comes to a tough guy bro
you know man he's got a [ __ ] great
story he's another guy that's smoking
crack and yeah yeah because he did my
podcast with felicia and that time he
opened up about the crack and the
[ __ ]
living in the car but that's interesting
he is one of those guys because i still
remember doing
sets with him at the ice house yeah and
this was way before he was hitting right
he had a way before the movie with tom
cruise
this was way before that he did that
movie with a benisso del toro yeah
traffic traffic this is before traffic
like i've known him you know you always
saw him at auditions and he gave you
love and [ __ ] yeah that listen this is a
weird [ __ ] place so
okay yesterday morning
i have this thing i get to an airport
and let's say my la gate is gate 60 all
right i'll go to gate 55 and play guess
who's from l.a
all right i could be in any [ __ ] town
in this country
name a [ __ ] town and i could sit
there and pick the people that are going
to be on that plane now let me be honest
with you guys i'm 50 wrong most of the
time
but the other 50 i'm flat on because the
only people who fly a mini skirts with
heels is people from my life
the only people who were the only women
who would wear yoga pants with those
high boots
and their hair and
women from l.a the only guys who would
wear shoes with no socks and you could
see their feet
the guys from l.a the only people who
would get on a plane
and [ __ ] wear shorts and flip-flops
are people from l.a you know it's just a
filthiness it's a dirty it's a different
animal they're either they're either
very uh
there's a word that people call it
they're very uh
they expect everything they have an
entitled they have an air of entitlement
like i came home to columbus so i came
home to baltimore i came home to
cincinnati but i'm a big shot in l.a and
now i'm a big shot here in my hometown
but those towns don't give a [ __ ] right
like some of those towns yeah the circle
that you grew up with and your little
friends at starbucks but most of people
like i'm out here banging shoveling snow
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're a writer
on a show or anything like that so i get
to the airport
i get out of the car i tip the driver
i turn around i'm walking into the
airport and i stop and i take two hits
off the vapor pan i already smoked the
joint i drank a protein shake on the way
of the airport
and i hear the gates open up you know
the doors like when you step in front of
them
and i see this [ __ ] dude
walk with his little [ __ ] [ __ ] shoes
on
and
his little shirt on a little tighter
than usual i'm not saying he's gay he
wasn't gay at all and he had two bags
okay
i just see him and i say to myself look
at this [ __ ] la punk
just in my head right so i walk in the
airport boom i see alaska airlines i got
upgraded to first class i go right to
first class and i'm the first one online
now the other line the other line had
like six people there
that were waiting to get online all
right
i'm getting ready the guy turns around
he leaves it's my turn to go up and all
of a sudden this dude with the two bags
walks in front of me willie
you're number one and you got number one
right i mean it's just number one no no
i'm the guy checking in i'm checking
into my flight right he walks right in
front of me now i'm sitting there
for [ __ ] uh
for 30 seconds
going what the [ __ ] just happened
what the [ __ ] just happened
and something inside of me i already had
my license out and he was looking for
his yeah and as he was looking for his
over here i stepped right here willie i
put my elbow here and i gave the ticket
to the guy and he goes what's going on i
go
i was next and the guy turns when he
goes no you're behind me i go i was next
dog
don't even go there i was next all right
but when i went in with my elbow he says
i kind of hit him in the neck
i didn't hit him in the [ __ ] neck i
just said you ain't getting in there he
was over here like this looking over
here to his right hand side you know
straight you know hold on one second
you have time you have nothing better to
do than stand there while i look for my
[ __ ] license which should be the [ __ ]
out already you know what i'm saying
you're flying right it should be out
already so i cut right in front of my oh
this isn't the guy goes you're after me
i go not not right now dog i've been
standing on that [ __ ] line for the
last two minutes you're not just gonna
[ __ ] walk here and the dude goes
where i know some tsa was right there
and the dude walks over he goes what
happened
and he goes this man and the guy i
didn't assault him did i know like he
tried to cut me off and i came in here i
was the next one online and i go number
one are you do you have a first class
ticket he goes no
you see what i'm saying
so he starts to make this big thing
that harassment i didn't harass nobody
yeah he was one of those [ __ ] l.a
dudes harassment and you know i should
contact my attorney can i take your
[ __ ] attorney but i'm getting on the
[ __ ] plane [ __ ]
so i get on the [ __ ] plane i don't
see him i see dion cole
i see rob schneider
i'm talking to them they're all on the
same flight i get on my [ __ ] seat
i sit down
and he's like [ __ ] three people to
the end
and i stick my foot out just in case
he's gonna get stupid with me so i could
kick him directly in the heel
and push myself up over my right and
throw him against the wall
and he makes eye contact with me like
you [ __ ] type eye contact yeah yeah i
look him straight in the face and i go
get to the dungeon [ __ ]
and he just turned pale and there we go
willie you know how much abuse i take at
airports i was telling lee
about three months ago i get on a
[ __ ] plane now i always get a certain
seat
i always get the same seat bro
if i pay for a plane ticket i get the
same seat okay every time that's my seat
i don't give a [ __ ]
so one day i go to this seat and this is
dude again johnny hollywood
talking to some [ __ ] other guy about
you know variety and all this [ __ ] right
and i come over and i go that's my city
goes no it's my seat
and for a minute oh my [ __ ] maybe i made
a mistake i got too high when i got this
plane ticket
and i don't have my glasses on i can't
really see
but i knew it was one i knew i was in
one so i sat down
i'm sitting there and all of a sudden
some lady comes up and she's like you're
in my seat
and i go what and she goes you're on my
ceiling hold on let me check one second
well no you're right i am in your seat i
go up to the guy i go hey man
you're in my city goes go find another
seat
do me a favor though get the [ __ ] up it
was six in the morning i'm in no [ __ ]
move for this [ __ ] get the [ __ ] up
get the [ __ ] up this door just comes
over what's going on this guy this is my
seat and he tells me to go find another
[ __ ] seat he goes well no i meant to
you to take mice i don't want your
[ __ ] seat i paid for this seat i'm
delighted come on let's go and the
[ __ ] guy next to him johnny executive
is like what's going on yeah bro i pay
for this seat i'm not gonna go sit in
the [ __ ] corner if i want to sit in
the corner i would have got that [ __ ]
seat don't you think about you this
happens to me bro constantly on [ __ ]
planes dog and they're all la people
that go somewhere and they feel more
entitled to something when they like
they feel special like they're more
special now that they went home and they
got that uh vindication whatever the
[ __ ] happens bro this always happens to
me
always i had beefs with germans on the
plane one time in new york the cops came
i had another b for the guy on the way
to columbus ohio in front of me bro i
always get into the [ __ ] beast
oh my god what
um there's this instagram account the
lady who once had followed me and i just
went to check it it's called passenger
shaming i wanna can i show you some of
these pictures of what people do on
planes yeah it's hysterical it's like
it's it's it's a huge account and then
it's just i can't imagine i'm i'm glad
that you stood up to them because i
think a lot of people no you can't do
this [ __ ] not today not not in the six
nine in the morning dawg
you're not gonna cut in front of me at
six the [ __ ] clock in the morning
oh the feet up
so yeah look at this garbage
yeah they're filthy [ __ ] people they
got no class
these are filthy [ __ ] people you're
gonna put your filthy [ __ ] feet out
on a plane like that i don't even take
my shoes off i'm so [ __ ] embarrassed
i know my that smells like [ __ ]
look at this filthy [ __ ]
i would do something to that
[ __ ]
what is that
fingernails oh no she's not getting on
the [ __ ] plane
that creepy [ __ ]
oh someone has a shirt off
yeah bro no no no
put their jacket over your tv screen
that would i would kill that with that
no they have to take it all right let's
do this to take the jacket from him
oh what the [ __ ] is that dirty banding i
how about this one i found this one uh
yesterday you want to hit this bong
willie this will put you over the top
yeah this is betty boop
meets [ __ ] lawrence taylor
all right man you don't need this in
your life
no i don't know listen the first thing i
do you know what i got in my bag dog
what's that when i fly
i got extra strength my wife
i make my wife me and my wife take the
[ __ ] extra strength
what's that [ __ ] dog what's that lysol
the heavy duty one right yeah and i put
in a baggie and i have the wipes
and i wipe everything down on the
[ __ ] plane do you understand me
i win everything down dog
turn that way brother now you're gonna
kill my [ __ ] ears i'm sorry bro
yeah i wipe everything [ __ ] down dog
this is why
this is why i don't the the thing where
i put my seat my head my head where i
rest my head that's the first thing i
wipe i don't want [ __ ] crabs what's
that someone's warming up their pizza
with the overhead light
yeah no no no no i don't need that
you know this kid last week was saying
he travels with earplugs
bro you gotta that's the problem with
people they get they they don't fly a
lot and they're not prepared
if you're not prepared to [ __ ] fly
it's gonna be a long goddamn week dog
you gotta [ __ ] be prepared to fly
nowadays and i know a lot of people
listening to going joey you really bring
handy wipes on the [ __ ] plane you bet
your goddamn ass i do
you bet your [ __ ] goddamn ass i do i
don't know whose head was on that thing
they don't clean those planes they don't
do a [ __ ] thing bro they straighten
out the magazines
and they they go like this and that guy
comes in with a little vacuum and that's
it everything else is not sanitized
that's not that's why they stopped
giving pillows remember there was yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no man no
more pillows you got to be [ __ ] crazy
if you're going to fly and you don't
wipe [ __ ] down
i know people listen like joey you got
to be [ __ ] kidding me i'm telling you
dog i don't like my head resting on that
stuff
you know it's just not good for you it
can't be good for you
20 heads you don't know who's been on
there this
bjojo's on there there's definitely
lights on there now so
from the time you shoot your special to
how long is your special
to be ready
uh it should be ready in about a month
okay it's gonna take about a month to
add at the editors or you're editing
yourself yeah i know i got an editor
look joey man i'm telling you bro i'm
probably selling my car
to uh getting the
you know getting the whole funding done
man
do you know what i mean really yeah bro
because it's it's like i okay originally
it was the x amount of money right right
and then i went
went in the red with the money that i
had you know i had a lot of money saved
up
and then i just got uh the guy that's
putting it all together
he goes hey willie we're gonna go we
gotta go a little further
and i was like i got you bro don't worry
about it just get it done oh you need
that let's do it you want to get the jib
it's gonna cost me this much all right
okay let's get the gym man let's do it i
want it done right but you know what
joey it's just i know that uh i know
it's gonna be good i know the material i
know how it's been received around the
clubs you know you know what i mean you
know when you you yeah i don't know i'm
not saying that i'm just saying that
i just want you to have a plan you don't
know
and with all the streaming services now
you're not gonna have a plan selling at
all all right you know i got to tell you
something
the other night i was up late
saturday night i couldn't sleep
and i watched one of those showtime
comedy specials
they're not for me i don't ever want to
go on showtime
ever hey ever
you could just tell they looked
there's something i knew in the
beginning he even pulled me aside
over at your [ __ ] thing and he was
like bro why don't you go with us
i go i don't want a showtime
right i don't need showtime in my life
that's garbage i don't even care for
show time go that's garbage all right
showtime has always been garbage for the
last 15 [ __ ] years
i put one thing on there and i was more
embarrassed enough that's it it was time
to move on
i was also on stars too that does
nothing for you either all right they
asked me for the pitch stars i'm like
not in a million [ __ ] years no how
many people have stars four
who's got stars
four [ __ ] people remember that kid
used to do that show on stars
with with they paid uh he was jim
kellum's client
he got he did something he's the one
that got booed at somebody's
oh i know he's
the famous boo guy that was his name
put that on lee the guy what the [ __ ]
was his name he got blew that who's
roast
somebody's roast or something like that
yeah
he was married to a boy i haven't seen
him in years
he
sold that show with
martin okay so martin got sixty percent
of the money for coming out and going
like this
like what uh what's his name used to do
at the end of death jam yeah
just just wave yeah wave yeah so i did
his show
nobody has ever come up to me it's that
scion stars yeah no not one [ __ ]
person
like nobody's got stars so that that's
the other thing knowing where you want
to take your special like knowing like i
knew i did not want to go no no no no
not even in the [ __ ] clothes so that
was the thing i'm lucky that
you know my agent talked to cecil i'm
[ __ ] lucky
netflix didn't want me and that was fun
i was just happy to put it out and i was
happy that it all worked out you know
you always get [ __ ] with those things
as long as you know that going in
you know you're always going to get
[ __ ] and i'm saying all right you know
nobody makes unless you're dane cook
and they give you 500 000
up front
that's the only time you don't make
money on these people unless and that's
the people at home
you know i tell you these things so you
know you know unless you're a big name
you're not making money and you're
[ __ ] special yeah okay they tell you
some story you get a little money up
front and they sing you some [ __ ]
song and you know what
you go to yourself i'm gonna do a good
job and i'm gonna sell enough tickets
and i'll make up the difference in five
or six years you know that's how you
have to go into anything but i've spoken
to 20 comics who are bitter about
certain companies or whatever right and
when i went into it i got i went with
the attorney that they recommended and
then my wife went to her attorney and it
was two completely different [ __ ]
things you could see the people that are
in bed with people like let's go to
montreal you're going to be there yeah
no you don't want that guy's your
attorney
all right i don't want that guy he's my
attorney i don't want a guy that has 20
comedians
he has relationships yes but he's also
more passive because he's got
relationships with these people
i got a [ __ ] real jewish lady who was
like why
are they getting this mark that off and
even the attorney that we paid said
oh she's never they're never gonna okay
watch my [ __ ] heat [ __ ] all right
they okay then you know and that's you
have to just cover yourself more there
you know for years i never used an
attorney
i don't go anything and then when you
get robbed you cry
it's like every [ __ ] week now i get
hit
the laugh factory
those other thieves that are online
we're gonna put your video up and give
you 50 of the earnings you go to your
videos got a million downloads and they
haven't sent you a check in two [ __ ]
years now when people hit me up i just
tell them no and if i see that stuff and
we're with a service now that if you see
me put up your [ __ ] we [ __ ] come and
take the money now we copyright and we
take the [ __ ] money no more no today
i had to tell somebody they hit me up we
have these videos a year we like to put
on our youtube channel don't put them up
because i'm going to have my attorney
contact your attorney and we're going to
take all the 100
so before that happens don't even put it
up
you know people are getting cute now you
know i don't want
listen man for
when you start making money as a comic
trust me there's 10 years there where
you just get [ __ ] robbed you look at
a check and you look at it and go god
damn they used to rob me years ago you
ever you could start getting with a nice
agent or something even featuring you're
like wow
i'll never forget frank kelly the guy
who had sticky fingers
frank kelly got fired from john levens
that was a solid mic oh
that dude was solid when he was on
sticky fingers yeah that dude unlike
montoya my montoya got accused of sticky
fingers yeah
well the frank kelly was a sticky finger
dude but frank kelly gave you a taste of
the action right when he got to john
lovitz he was stealing and when i found
out he got caught i was pissed off
because
when he was robbing at the improv he was
giving us a piece of the i featured one
weekend everybody else paid me 500 a
week to feature he gave me 1500.
i was like 15 [ __ ] 100. but he robbed
a thousand off the top that was he
figured out a way how to rob 2500
pay me 15. he put a thousand in this
pocket he had them wired bro
he had the improvs wired he was
five steps above the improv
they were seeing the minimum payment bro
he even worked he worked out bro one
time i brought i did irvine
for like 70 of the door and i had rogan
as the headliner and i can't tell you
the check they gave rogan and rogan
didn't want it he goes give it to joe i
go no no take it for your kids you're
gonna need this someday i go well
there's no money left for me jesus
christ he gave me a check i paid
everybody twice
because i felt so guilty i paid
everybody double what i told him that's
how much frank kelly stole but he stole
and he chopped it up with you
these other [ __ ] robbed you and
they don't give you a taste of dick his
thief would honor man yeah he was a
thief but when he went coming up john
lovitz
he robbed him blind and he didn't give
me a taste of that i had to wait for
checks two weeks and they bounced and
[ __ ]
i'm happy willie that you're putting
this together on your own this listen
willie
always remember
in today's right now with what's going
on
this is the best time to do [ __ ] on your
own
i shot a special in vegas that was [ __ ]
because i had [ __ ] people around me they
were all [ __ ]
i believed them they were all [ __ ] they
were all [ __ ]
and i was cheap i didn't hire a
production manager
you know when i saw this special i knew
i [ __ ] up because i had a stain on my
shirt
you know what i'm saying i tried to be a
puerto rican and i got what i got coming
to me you're following me that's the
problem with those things that
i said oh
[ __ ] six thousand i'll shoot it what
a waste
it was like i just should have taken
that six thousand lit it on fire right
there was nothing i could do with that
the sound was horrible
the shirt was horrible there's nothing
you could do you can't even sell that
even when they come to you ten years
from now if i became a big like richard
pryor and we're like we want everything
we want joey's vault
they would say not that
send that back
you know what i'm saying like if if i
had a vault of material and they would
go well you know he's dead now sell it
to us nobody would want that you can't
do nothing with it
if you look at it there's a big stain on
my shirt right and then it sounds game
end yeah andover yeah that was it you
know the one that i have on netflix
right now
um
i um i was half producer of that one
like all that i own
you know
you know for i got an investor
and everything that he put in like we
went dollar for dollar
but i'm the one that arranged the whole
thing on that one like the cameras the
sound the sound every i got everybody
and this guy just came in because i
needed some money with the uh you know
putting it together
and and so i learned from that one john
you make a profit your partner
yeah well a little bit you know he got
his money back yeah yeah and he made a
little taste yeah
yeah yeah a little bit yeah
but it's not like these deals that we
hear man right now here these guys are
getting these deals bro 40 million 20
million what the [ __ ] man
it's uh do you guys even get jealous or
is that just such a high number you
don't think it's like a i don't think
about it there's no reason to be jealous
i mean
listen man
if somebody's willing to pay you
i can't be [ __ ] jealous
if you got them to 40 [ __ ] million
dollars
you know
netflix has how many million subscribers
at 9.95 a month what are you [ __ ]
kidding me they got deep pockets
so i can never be no i don't listen man
when somebody puts out a special i
learned something in 2000 that to move
forward you cannot have any jealousy man
or no bad feelings like for you to get
ahead as a as a comic
or as whatever you want to call yourself
an artist
once you start dwelling on other people
and what they have and what they don't
have
your [ __ ] goes down the tubes yeah this
[ __ ] goes down the tubes
you can't compare your progress to
anybody else's man once you start
comparing your progress
to anybody else's
[ __ ] happens you're doing comedy five
years
you work hard every night you write well
you're featuring at the improv and also
there's a kid that never even emceed
never even emceed he just jumped over mc
and he's featuring who's been he's been
doing comedy two years you can't figure
it out he gets a tv show there you are
struggling 10 years in he's on drugs now
he's all [ __ ] up you're still fighting
for your life and now comes the 12 year
mark you get the tonight show your
career is rocking and rolling and this
guy's in the [ __ ] rehab because he
moved too [ __ ] fast all right
i've seen people come to this town
and you see the movement you go
they move too fast you know kevin hart
hit he had a tv show it failed
it's not like he just kept going yeah tv
show failing made him gave him momentum
yeah gave him strength he called his
agent he goes i want to go on the road
every week
for 1500 a week and i want you to give
away every ticket in the house to people
so that's exactly what the improv did
and he went out there every weekend for
two [ __ ] years and he got 1500 to
1800 people to see him every [ __ ]
week
he did it the old-fashioned way kevin
hart deserves every dime he makes i wish
him nothing but he came back from how
many people come back from the show
failing not too many
not too many
you know bill burr was on a show early
on with stars
and on an abc and the show caved
he [ __ ] picked his boots up went back
to boston started from [ __ ] scratch
and went to new york got on chappelle
and bill burr is who he is because he
didn't take off like that right you know
yeah you get little breaks along the way
but those guys that come to holly with
him right away you see him at the improv
they got nine jews with them
everybody's got a suit you know what i'm
saying then you see them at the comedy
store then they go to montreal and then
and then they have a three a three
picture deal with whatever you know what
bro and also you're like whatever
happened to all that [ __ ] yeah what have
happened to all those deals and all that
tv show i went through a thousand of
those guys
and i think for about two years i was
not jealous but i
uh not infatuated myself but what's the
word like i thought about it
well if willie got fifty thousand i
should be able to get thirty five
thousand you know like i got i started
comparing myself like that and then
something happened one day i said you
know what
i just got to be me
you just have to not worry about what
people get
when people get something you say god
bless them and you move [ __ ] forward
that's all you can do bro and hopefully
you'll spin around and
that's one more number closer for you
all right do you know what i'm saying
yeah absolutely but i i
like i said i
my energy goes on me because i'm on my
writing a lot of people i've had people
ask like wow you've been doing it so
long and don't you get tired of it i
said no because i love to sit down
and create
you know my my uh my high
from you know obviously
it's also tequila but my other high
is um
i love like getting an idea
comes from nowhere
and then just trying to create something
out of nothing and when you do it you go
on stage and you try it and it's kind of
funny and and then you listen to the
recording and you go well maybe i you
know twist it this way and add this to
it and then you know you're molding it
and you're sanding it you know you know
bro and then
you know and then when you got a
polished you know
uh a piece of wood and you you say man i
remember when this was just
bark
you know no it's a and then anyway
that's that's where i
that's why i uh you've always been an
artist in that sense you've always been
a wordsmith you always have the tape
recorder where you always have the
notebook with you i went to see your
writing operation
at denny's
they don't allow nobody to pass the
[ __ ] ropes
it's uh
it's really [ __ ] interesting like i
learned a lot that little process from
you and i was struggling after the
special i struggled for like two months
on stage man coming with new stuff yeah
struggled big and now at least i got a
little voice i got something coming from
here a little something coming from here
i got a little something working over
here so now i gotta find the connection
if i shoot another special won't be till
next february maybe you know i don't
even need the aggravation that's good
time for me that's what you got but you
gotta
listen bro you got something that a lot
of people don't have
you know
and i don't care they say uh
you know everybody's the same you work
this way and everybody's the same
and you just you have a uh i don't know
if you guys it's in dna man it must have
been your mom or your dad but somebody
was a hell of a [ __ ] storyteller man
you know and i don't know i don't know
if you know when you were a kid if it's
your mom was talking she would tell
these stories and then you picked up on
it but but
you know it's a gift that you have but
with you is
is i it's it's already the cake's done
it's just you know okay what kind of
frosting we're gonna use
you know you want you want strawberries
on that but but the hard part is the
cake man
because you know sometimes i sit down
with you just shooting the [ __ ] like
when we before we started the show we're
just shooting this [ __ ] and i'm
god damn this guy's [ __ ] you know you
just you're just a [ __ ] smooth
man storyteller bro when people say that
the other day it was the funniest thing
my computer didn't work at this [ __ ]
hotel sadly i had to restart it
restarted restarted
and finally i restart this [ __ ] thing
mirrors was on the fritz huh mirrors was
on the fritz mary's i don't know what
the [ __ ] i have that that that
computer's [ __ ] window by the way let
me just say this uh joey you know you've
known me for more than what 20 years
yeah listen i i don't know
i don't pander
i i don't i'm not gonna kiss nobody's
ass if anything you know i have a bad
reputation for not getting along with
people right no no no so if i'm telling
you man no no you scared the [ __ ] at me
when you said that to me like you told
me at the dinner one day you go you have
that in your corner work that angle and
that's why i didn't do the machine gun
style stuff i used to do
because i'm learning all this stuff like
the the one
that got me a couple weeks ago well i
was telling you the story about facebook
so i get on facebook on a saturday which
i never get on facebook on a saturday
but a buddy of mine was going to send me
a link to some [ __ ] thing he had
so he kept calling me did you get the
link did you get the link i go bro my
computer's [ __ ] up
you know and i hit facebook my facebook
is so [ __ ] up on my computer that
instead of getting my home page i get
the back page with all these things
right
and somebody had posted something i
don't even know what the [ __ ] it was
and they would post like this guy is a
great storyteller
this guy's a great storyteller this
guy's a great story and there was a
bunch of people and i i don't even know
what made me look at it i thought it was
more of a high level type thing and also
on the bottom some guy wrote [ __ ] all
you [ __ ]
mad flavor could [ __ ] them all up
something's just crazy and they
responded back like [ __ ] you
this guy's way better like they were you
know they were jack guys they didn't
know what the [ __ ] i'm uh no
i'm learning about this [ __ ] now it's
not like you strive or take a
storytelling class one-on-one yeah
there's no storytelling class one-on-one
i was just around a lot of characters
right growing up
and when they told you a story i
remember them taking you there like
that's the most important thing that i
would sit there and go wow and then go
what the [ __ ] just happened
they're taking you there they lullaby
you
you know you have to know when to raise
your voice when to load when to speed it
up you know the same thing with stand-up
comedy yeah we have tricks why everybody
listen man
you know
everybody knows you're you're you're
you're the best storyteller in town man
everybody everybody knows that crazy i
feel flattered but i think ron white is
better
i'm not saying i'm not a i'm not a fan i
don't like his material bro but
i just just feel that you're
you know listen
that's just uh
it is what it is thank you brother i
think you're a great writer so that's
why
the special worked out you know exactly
where to put different things but
everybody picks up
you can't be good at everything and
that's one thing that
a lot of comedians they have ego that
they won't accept help
i love getting help in all areas when i
get into something i love getting out
i love going to jiu jitsu and some guys
[ __ ] me up
in the middle of that he goes put your
elbow here
wow like that right right right that
won't let me [ __ ] put my leg there
you know
when i don't like comics who come up to
me like i don't take tags from comics
and the word got out
a long time ago so comics really don't
come with any tags well the words out
for people not to come up to you period
bro really yeah because you're yeah
listen man you're not an [ __ ] but
you're one of those dudes where if
you're not gonna talk to me and say
something
the [ __ ] away from me if somebody talks
to you they gotta
they're coming up like hey joy you know
what but they're not gonna eat i'm not
gonna
you're not going out there and and small
talk about somebody's [ __ ] dan or or
hey that people might have come to me
all the [ __ ] time
sometimes i'm high and i don't even know
what to say
sometimes i have they don't understand
that they're throwing me the [ __ ] off
right when people say [ __ ] to me at
airports and [ __ ] they have no idea
they're throwing me for a [ __ ] loop
this that i still think i feel so guilty
like i [ __ ] go home and think about
it because they don't understand how
like about three months ago on my
[ __ ] taco place
and i you know when you leave here lee
sometimes we leave here and we can eat
our finger
you know what i'm saying like you're
looking at your finger on the drive home
i get to the taco place i order four
[ __ ] tacos
i sit down
i'm not down two minutes i put salsa on
the taco
and i look at it to go like this and i
get can we take a picture i go [ __ ] no
like i just told them [ __ ] no bro i just
sat the [ __ ] down are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] do you know how [ __ ] hungry
i am
dawg i can't tell you how bad i feel
today if you're listening to the podcast
my apologies
another time i got super [ __ ] hot
and went to the park
and i was doing kettlebells this had to
be three years ago
i'm at north hollywood park stoned to
the gills
degree weather
doing kettlebells with no shirt on fat
as i am
getting sun on my titties i believe i
went to the doctor and they gave me a
blood test because bro your vitamin d
levels
are horrible because but don't feel bad
60 percent of californians test loaf of
vitamin d because they don't go out in
the sun they think it's [ __ ] like
the the devil
so i would go to
uh whatever the [ __ ] north hollywood
park
i'd get stoned i would that's when
banana bread was around
and i'd eat this banana bread that would
[ __ ] me up and i'd go in that park with
a gallon of water
and i would swing kettlebells and do
squats and i would walk across
with the things why i don't know
i could have died of a [ __ ] heart
attack out there but i go into a tree
and one day these two dudes came up to
me like hey joey what's happening bro i
have music on
you know like when you have your
earphones yeah you're deep in the song
and these guys came up to me and i took
my earphones off and i could feel the
moisture and [ __ ]
and i just looked at him with a look
like
they're like hey man how you doing we
trained with whatever we just wanted to
come over and say hello
i didn't know what they were talking
about willie
like i was that high into my [ __ ] that
much that until they left like when i
got in the car i said what happened 20
minutes ago
what the [ __ ] were they talking about
that [ __ ] keeps me up at night
that [ __ ] keeps me up at night because
i think that right now they're going
that dude was a douchebag because he did
that but they don't understand that they
caught me off guard like i'm [ __ ]
stoned what are you talking about
you want to take a picture that last
friday in baltimore some guy came up to
me and started asking me questions about
20 years ago
finally his girlfriend caught on like
she's like doug
why are you asking those type of
questions
and i looked at him i go i just did two
[ __ ] hours
you want to [ __ ] play jeopardy get
the [ __ ] out of here he just looked at
me okay
because you can't be that stupid
you can't be this [ __ ] stupid
i do the podcast monday and wednesday
every week sometime sunday all right you
know how many times i get hit up on
thursday for a shout out
but can i get a shout out on your next
podcast let me tell you something i'm
not doing a podcast on [ __ ] monday
you know what's gonna happen to your
stupid [ __ ] name
i'm gonna forget the [ __ ] thing you
wanna shout out you gotta hit me out
monday at a certain time you gotta keep
trying that's the only way i'll [ __ ]
remember i don't remember these people
tell me at the shows give me a shot are
you [ __ ] crazy i forget when i go to
the [ __ ] thing it's the saddest thing
bro we getting home
i'm getting old what the [ __ ] you want
in fact let me do some shout outs i know
willie got to go and [ __ ] we're over
here talking [ __ ] really i'm proud of
you no it takes balls to shoot your own
[ __ ] special in this town everybody
wants to be on that everybody wants to
be you know
hank cooper
bobby friedman arse warrior ollie boss
who i haven't heard from if you're
listening hit me up with an email jeremy
campbell
rory valentine malcolm riddle who came
to the show his little partner cassius
morris up there slinging dick up in the
great [ __ ] state of canada
and ricky malin said and happy birthday
to my man danny b you know i love you
[ __ ]
so that's it you're shooting
saturday night at the ice house 8 7 30
and what time yeah uh it's uh 8 and 10
on saturday and 8 and 10 uh on friday
you know saturday's looking pretty good
so man for all all your your people that
uh you know they want to come down
please come on down if you're not doing
nothing you're close to the ice house go
on down support the guy see what the
looks if you've never seen this a
special get shot be a part of something
support you never know
maybe someday you might need the [ __ ]
uh some help yourself lee what's going
on with you how you feeling buddy i'm
feeling good i think i think i might go
down on saturday to support willie you
think you're gonna go down that good
you're a good man thank you brother of
course you're going to take the wife
with you of course nice
get out of the house get some air well
one more once every six months get some
nice [ __ ] cheeseburgers up there and
pasadena has got to be something good i
know last time you ate in pasadena it
wasn't good
oh yeah those wings are terrible uh i'll
find something on yelp i'm sure all
right willie always a pleasure man thank
you love you on and
talk about different [ __ ]
now the special last time you won it was
because you were helping me oh they're
helping each other thank [ __ ] guys i
got to tell you brother i you know i've
done four specials you know
i was back in the day with jay i was on
on the tonight show a dozen times
but to me you know uh because in the
comedy world bro you know you're you're
a guy that it's uh
it's something that i it was an honor
when you when you asked me to it was and
it was bro
please so it's up there people go so
what do you do man you know i work with
joey man so
you bad [ __ ] you
first off how about a shout out to my
main [ __ ] on it for all your
health
supplements your your weight supplements
from alpha brain
to shroom tech to have protein to new
mood
go to honor.com look at the great
selection of supplements they got look
at this
steel
bats i can't get your discount on
weights and kettlebells but on all
supplements i'll get you ten percent off
go to honor.com right now and press in
church like a bad [ __ ] and get
ten percent off delivered to your house
number two like i said before if you've
been settling for store-bought underwear
five packs i got something that's going
to change your life for the better you
ready me undies what's the first thing
you put on the last thing you take off
it's underwear make your most important
piece of clothing the best it could be
with me undies you're sitting there
scratching your head going what the [ __ ]
is me on these oh just seriously soft
feel good on these delivered right to
your door me undies are designed in la
and made from substantially sourced
micro modal a fabric three times softer
than cotton me undies softer than soft
luxe undies come in ever-changing
selection of classic colors bold shades
and adventurous patterns so you can
tailor your undies to your own personal
style and guess what you can save time
and money each month with a monthly
subscription how's that and if you're
not ready for a subscription that's okay
you can still save that's because me on
these is offering you
20 off your first pair
just use our special url meundies.com
joey and get 20 off your first pair so
go ahead revamp your underwear draw you
deserve it once again that's
meundies.com
joey let me ask you something stop
settling for open mic comedy when the
legends are all at your fingertips cecil
puts you on the guest list for exclusive
comedy shows from legendary comics and
today's top talent with the new
exclusive special from nick apollo and
fahim anwar who we had on here you
understand me nick apollo gina
yashaya and a new special from hamid
faheem anwar did you know that laughing
can burn up to 120 calories an hour that
means c shows hundreds of hours of
streaming stand-up television and
original comedy is basically a gym
membership and that means your couch is
basically an epileptical an elliptical
not for you lee you [ __ ] and those gas
station nachos are basically a salad not
for you lee [ __ ] so your new
year's resolution is basically kept
attention comedy nerds come to a magical
place called seesaw where new stand-up
comedy specials debut
every month it's like flying around the
world to see great stand-up comedy in
the country except your arms won't get
tired
last year a comedy arena was born with
stand-ups rome looking to slay audiences
they call that arena ceso where no laugh
is spared and no punchline is left
behind
let's do this
with cecil you get unlimited access to
cso original series next day late night
and hilarious stand-up special
binge-worthy classics including
42 seasons of saturday night live
plus cecil brings stand up right to your
living room with exclusive content from
today's best comedians all right sign up
now and catch a brand new stand-up from
her fajima moi nick depaolo and your
uncle joey or watch your favorite sets
from comedians like louis ck amy schumer
and hannibal barris you can access cso
from anywhere anytime using ios android
windows xbox one you ready for a
punchline here you go
ceso 399 per month no joke 399 per month
for unlimited comedy anytime anywhere
but ready
just go to cso.com right now
and sign up for two free weeks with the
promo code joey at checkout so again go
to cso.com
spelled s e e s o dot com promo code
joey again cso.com
promo code joey
thank you very much we'll be back
wednesday [ __ ] night ready to
rock hope you have a great day and a
great week stay black don't forget
my man willie barcena friday and
saturday ice house and don't forget
tickets are going fast next thursday
march 30th the [ __ ] april fool's day
i'm at the levity live and nyack don't
[ __ ] around all right a bunch of people
coming up there renee and carcione
lady j we got a bunch of undercover
[ __ ] agents and the week after that
420 levity live and oxnard one more time
willie barcena lee syed and uncle joey i
love you [ __ ] stay black have a
great week i'll see you [ __ ] on
wednesday
you